even TV newsrooms sometimes struggle to
sort out facts from fiction South Africa
news anchor Iman repetti knows that
false statements from politicians can
easily be taken as truth if left
unchecked Iman uses Africa check her
secret weapon on the net an agency like
this helps to trace things backwards and
even if they reach a point of no
conclusion it allows us to say huh we
need to think about where we get our
information from and how we use it I
name fun Vic works for the nonprofit
organization Africa check in
Johannesburg she and her team researched
the credibility of politicians public
statements they've earned a reputation
for the thoroughness of their work and
for their unbiased independence we try
our best suit to be seen as a credible
and independent and nonpartisan
organization by making best use of the
best sources and also being transparent
in the way we write up our report and
then over time to check all sides of the
debates and all political parties so
that people don't think we were anti the
government or aunty opposition parties
or anti anybody and we just were just
interested in facts I name and her
fellow campaigners work in five
countries Africa check is funded by
several independent institutions and
foundations that support factual and
independent journalism the work isn't
always easy we often battle with
government officials to get their
information we need even though it's
paid for by public money and they have
it available we often wait months and
months for our queries to be answered
and then the other big problem is that
often statistics in Africa are outdated
or there's not enough research on the
suunto topics Africa check is always on
top of the latest headlines and it's
free of charge for public use
for television anchor Iman repetti the
group's weekly reports have become a
reliable tool Africa check she says is
vital for strengthening young
democracies I think if you have an
independent agency that is a
non-political and it's not funded by any
agencies that have a vested agenda you
can trust the information a lot better
because it's almost like a clean filter
from which the information is coming
from and it is so so important Iman show
covers accusations of corruption against
the government and one of her frequent
guests is on infin week as Africa checks
influence continues to grow